Welcome to the lecture on database implementation.
So in the last lecture, we have looked at transaction concepts.
Today, we want to look at the second component here that we need, namely, it's a recovery component.
So basically, the recovery component is responsible for dealing with errors or in particular with crashes.
I mean, also with most of the errors, not only with crashes, but in particular, we have to make sure that everything survives after a crash.
This is the hardest case.
And for this, we basically use two kinds of mechanisms.
On the one hand, we make snapshots of the database,
which basically means backups.
As we take the database and we make a backup
from time to time.
And then we use log files to record all changes
that have occurred since a given point in time.
And so these are the two key components.
We now want to look at how this can be utilized
to guarantee crash recovery.
So a database snapshot is a copy of the database
in certain part of time.
So we basically just store it as it is.
And so the log file is a sequential list of all changes
that have been performed in the database instance.
And if we combine this to a copy from certain point of time
and all changes that occurred later,
database as it was at a later point in time.
So this is in a one slide summary, how we do recovery.
As now, as you would see in a moment,
the technical details are a bit more complicated than this,
but so it's a very high level.
This is the idea.
So we use a copy plus list of all changes,
and then we can reconstruct as it was.
Now, the third point here is obviously the main database,
the database snapshots on the log files should not be kept
on the same machine.
Yeah, this is obviously true.
the machine that contains your main data,
and you know that this can die in different ways,
so like your hard disk might break now,
hopefully you have a RAID system or so,
but nonetheless this can die too,
or even worse, you might have a fire
in your server room or something,
so then physically your machine is destroyed,
and of course you want to survive this,
and the trick to survive this
is to store these components here on a different machine,
ideally in a different building.
So that's a part a bit, so that if a fire occurs,
not both machines are destroyed.
So a separate machine is a minimum,
different building is better.
That is just to be more robust
concerning error scenarios that can occur.
And if this is the case,
then we can survive even pretty drastic error situations.
Okay, now, so how do we cope with system failure?
So this is now the simple case, so to say,
as we would see, this is not,
sometimes not as straightforward as written here,
but so in the simple case, it works like this.
So if a database is initially some state one,
then over time we apply a number of transactions.
So then this creates a state two here.
And now this state two is lost because,
you know, machine breaks.
And of course we want to reconstruct this state two.
Now, how do we do this?
We use two components.
So this means this backup here gives me a snapshot as it was in state 1.
So we assume we have a copy of state 1.
Then all the transactions are stored in the log file.
And now when we want to reconstruct my database, then I first restore my snapshot.
This again gives me state 1.
Then I look at my log file and I do a roll forward, which means I execute the transactions again.
Strictly speaking, we only execute the writes because transactions could in principle be
non-deterministic, therefore it is a bit dangerous to really execute the transactions.
So we redo the changes of the transactions.
This means that we do the same as the transactions did on the first execution.
This then brings me from state 1 to state 2 and then I have again my database state.
And that's why even though my hard disk here,
so this is the hard disk here was destroyed
for by some external event or so hardware failure.
Nevertheless, I can bring back my, all my data
by using the snapshot on the log file.
So this is a very high level overview of recovery.
Now, in a way this is an idealized view
because we believe that we have just some start state
and then some transactions in a log file
and then some, then at some point we realize,
is gone and then we have to reconstruct it as we will see there can be some more complex scenarios
like what we see here so we have again we have state one so then we so this is scenario here
where we assume you have memory loss also which means not just the system goes down in a clean way
But you know at some point we have a power failure or so the system goes away and you have no idea
So this is the following so we have again state 1 with initial state
Then I apply in the mob transactions here. This gives me state 2 and of course I've writes this to a log file
And then I have some more transactions TJ and you know, they are still running
Some of them might have been committed some of them might be active. Yeah, and then suddenly comes the power failure
The only pleasant thing is that, you know,
I don't really know what my state here on this box is.
So what is my state on disk?
I don't know.
Because it could be that some transactions
have already tried to write to disk
or are currently writing to disk.
So I said, I want to change these pages.
These pages are now written to disk.
Now the power failure comes,
was this page written or not?
So I cannot know this because I mean,
I mean, I might have submitted my change to the disk controller,
but I don't know if the disk controller performed right already.
And so therefore the state of my database is uncertain.
And this makes your recovery of course much more difficult.
Now because how should I roll forward my log file?
Because I don't know what is my state of disk.
So when power comes back again, I restart my machine.
Now I have a database file, sure, but I don't know, at least a priori I don't know, which
changes are in the file and which are not.
So what I want to do at the end is I want to take my database, I want to bring it into
some clean state and then use a log file to reconstruct first state 2, so this one that
is already finished and committed, and then the state 2 plus and 2 plus means I want to
reconstruct all changes by committed transactions, because they should be in there, and all changes
that were not committed must not be in there. So this is a challenge that we have. So everything
that was committed must be in the system again after we come back to power. Everything that was
not committed must not be in the system, even though it might be on disk already.
Now you know there could be a large transaction that writes a lot of records,
not committed yet, you run out of memory,
therefore the system writes it to disk,
just to get to free memory.
And then a power failure comes.
Then of course you must get rid of those changes.
And this is of course a more challenging case.
So how do we deal with restart
when my state on disk is uncertain?
So I don't know what has been written to disk
and what has not been written to disk.
Okay.
And last feature that we will also use from our transaction, from our recovery log here,
is we want to use a log file to abort a transaction. So to undo all the changes by a transaction.
And this of course can happen even without errors. So it can happen because the user,
for example, just types in SQL. So you just type rollback. Or of course there are many other ways
to trigger this.
And so this of course causes the transaction to abort.
Now we must remove all the changes by transaction.
And note that we need this functionality anyway, because if the system crashes, we must also
undo all uncommitted transactions.
Therefore, these aborting transactions, nothing really special.
So this functionality is needed for crash recovery.
Therefore, we can use the same mechanism for regular rollbacks too.
So, okay, this is just a special case.
Okay, now we want to look at more closely, like how can we implement this?
So these were more abstract descriptions, how does the real implementation work?
So first, we can look at the different kind of failure scenarios that occur.
And this, this differ in how much effort you have to spend.
So how easy are they to fix?
So the first error scenario, this is the most simple scenario,
it's not really a problem.
So this is here classified as local failure
with non-committed transactions,
like user issues a rollback or users are something invalid,
like compute one divided by zero or something.
And this is also a board of transaction.
So this means transaction has to be undone.
And the only thing we must do here is we must undo all changes
by that transaction, everything else is unaffected.
This is called R1 recovery.
the most simple kind of recovery.
We just undo what a single transaction did.
Now, the much harder scenario is this one.
Failure with loss of memory, second one.
So which means we crashed in a hard way
and we lost my memory content
and I don't know what is on disk.
Yeah, so now I must do two things.
These are called here R2 and R3 recovery.
First, I must make sure that everything
that has been committed is preserved, this is called R2 recovery.
And second thing, all non-committed transactions must be rollbacked.
So all changes that were not committed must be removed from the database system.
This is called R3 recovery.
Now depending how you implement your system, some of these steps might be a no-op.
For example, sometimes you can go away without R3 recovery, depending on how you have implemented
this.
But so these are basically the features we have to do.
local undo r2 redo all committed r3 undo all uncommitted and also the worst scenario of
course is this one here failure was loss of external memory so this is for recovery this
means really my server died in a brutal way so everything is gone and this now uh this is also
called media recovery so we really must reconstruct everything and this is of course the most
expensive and we hope that this never happens. I mean it can happen and of course we should be able
to cope with this, but media recovery is luckily not needed as usually as the other ones.
And so this here, the first one, this is very frequent, it occurs all the time.
And so this occurs all the time. This occurs from time to time, this we hope it never occurs,
but of course it can happen. Okay, now we have already talked of course about
a storage hierarchy, so we have external memory,
it's my database buffer.
Now as a tricky thing is that we don't,
in particular after we have crashed,
we don't really know how these two interact.
Now because I have some changes in my buffer,
some changes are on disk,
and I don't know what has been in my buffer
and what has been written to disk already.
And sometimes I really cannot know this
because this happens asynchronously.
Now like you have this page,
of course then at some point we write back, let's say here we have this page with C' and so then we
send to the disk, please write C'. Now so the page with C', please write this. We send this request
to the disk controller and say please perform the write, then we crash and when we come back again,
we cannot know, at least usually we cannot know, has the page C already been updated to C'? Yes or no?
So this is something that we cannot predict.
Therefore, we must somehow cope with this problem.
And so how difficult this problem is,
depends on how we implement our buffer manager.
So we have looked at this dimension previously in the lecture.
So basically we talk about steel and no steel.
So steel, no steel, and we look at force and no force.
So first steel and no steel.
which means a page that are modified by active transactions
must not be written back to disk.
So we only write back pages to disk
after everything has been committed on this page.
This of course means that the R3 recovery is not needed.
And so if I don't steal,
so then I know that only committed changes
are written to disk.
Therefore I don't have to worry that some parts
are written even though the transaction
has not been committed yet.
And you usually want to use a steel strategy because a steel strategy allows you to modify
data that is larger than your memory.
So if you run no steel, you cannot update something that is larger than memory because
otherwise you run out of pages.
So therefore usually we look at the more complex strategy here.
The same with force versus no force.
So force means when we commit, then we flush all changes to disk immediately.
your recovery easier because you know after I've committed my changes on disk.
Downside is we write to disk all the time and this is quite expensive.
Therefore for performance reasons we usually want to use a no-for strategy,
which means that if somebody commits we just say yes it's fine and we do not write it to disk
immediately. Of course later we will write it but not immediately. But of course this means
that when we crash we don't know if my transaction has been written to disk already or not.
Okay, as you see here the effects on recovery. So if I use the most simple variant, namely
force no steal, so this is the most simple box this means and I don't have to do redo because
the force strategy forced all my changes to disk. So I know if it's committed it's on disk.
And because I don't steal I don't have to do undo, because I only write things to disk if
they have been committed. On the other extreme if we look at the most generic one here, namely this
no force and steel.
This means I have to do redo because could be that my change
has not been written to disk already.
So I must reconstruct it and also must do undo
because I might have written something to disk
that was not committed yet.
And this of course requires me to undo the change.
And now usually we want to be in this box.
Now for performance reasons, this is the best box.
Of course also the most difficult box,
but nevertheless, it's the best.
Okay, now there are some more variations
So the effect recovery, like first question is how do you actually implement your update
strategy?
And also there are multiple ways to do this.
Perhaps most straightforward strategy here is update in place.
And also which means each page sits on disk and then when we do a modification we just
overwrite it and then provide the page back to disk later.
This is of course the best from a space perspective, because we just write it as it is, but it
has some compli- this requires some complicated recovery, potentially at least, because this
means that I might have data on disk that is not committed yet.
Now, the other two strategies we see here avoid this.
The first one, the most simple one, the so-called twin block approach.
Twin block means each page exists twice.
So we see a page a and 0 and 1, page p and 0 and 1 and so
So this is always a twin and now let's say this is my
My old database state then when you do an update you transform this into a prime
Now you have both and now when when you commit
Then you just remember that you switch all the 0 pages to all the 1 pages
Yeah, so then that's it
And if you crash, you just continue using the zero pages and don't worry about the one pages.
So we basically always have a committed state, either zero or one.
We update the other one and once we commit, we swap the role of both.
So this is pretty robust concerning crashes.
Downside is first you store everything twice, because we have double the space consumption.
Also, this switching here is not as simple as you might think.
Because you must be sure that all your pages are in the correct state.
So basically, because after you flip, you must be sure that both pages are in the correct
state because otherwise you have a problem when you continue running.
So it's not so super cheap.
Easy to implement but not very cheap.
The third variant here that we already talked about in the lecture here is shadow pages.
So we don't replicate everything as in the TwinBlock, but we only replicate the change
pages.
It gives you less redundancy, but it's even more complicated and you lose clustering.
And so it is all kind of difficult things.
Now by the way, there is one interesting problem here that we don't talk a lot about in the
lecture.
I think there is no other slide that talks about this.
But I want to mention here that in particular
was updated in place.
And this is a problem of so-called torn writes.
Torn writes are an absolute nightmare.
So what is a torn write?
Let's assume here, this is page A.
Now I want to write a new version of page A
and let's call this page A prime.
Now what could, it's not very likely of course,
but what could happen is,
but this is also a page and let's say for simplicity the old state contained a lot of ones
all of ones the new state contains a lot of twos yeah and what could conceivably happen is
then you you start to write then a power failure happens in a very inconvenient moment
and then the beginning of this page was updated already like you have a lot of twos here
but the end was not.
And this is a so-called torn write, a partial write.
So you try to write the whole page,
but in reality, you only wrote the half of the page.
And this is super, super difficult to prevent and to handle.
So this is an absolute nightmare.
So there are basically three approaches to take out this problem.
First approach, you use battery buffer disks.
the best.
So you have your disk control, you can buy disks that have a small battery in them that
guarantees that you can still flush out the write buffer.
So therefore the disk guarantees you that if you issue a write, this write will be done
either completely or not at all.
So you get a kind of atomicity on a write basis.
So this is, if you ask me, the best solution, because this solves this problem.
one that's for oil cost you a few euro and the problem is gone.
The unfortunate thing is most people don't have battery buffer disks.
You can buy them, but most people don't have them.
So now what do you do then?
So I think IBM had a solution where they first detected this problem.
And they detected this in a way like you have beginning of and end of your page,
you have a marker, a bit, a single bit that you use.
both is zero and whenever you write to the page you flip this so which means after the next update
both should be one yeah one and one and then when you do the next write you flip it again so which
both should be zero and so on yes you always alternate between this and now when you read
back a page you check if these two bits are consistent so if the bit at the beginning and
the bit at the end, it'll have the same value.
If yes, everything is good.
If not, we have encountered a tone right,
which means that my page here is damaged.
And if you do this, you start a full recovery.
Now, so you notify the user, say,
oh, I noticed that your media is corrupted.
Please do media recovery.
And then you do a full recovery.
And this is super invasive and expensive
and absolutely terrible.
Okay, so this is the second alternative to deal with this.
The third alternative is also somewhat expensive, but a bit more user friendly, because for
media recovery this requires that the user has a backup of your database.
Now of course we have previously said you should have a backup of your database in your
log file and you should store it in a different disk, but experience tells us should does not
mean you have.
Now so sometimes people simply don't have this, and then of course you have a problem.
When you turn right, of course your data is really damaged.
And therefore what other systems do, like for example, SQLite does it by default, Postgres
I'm not sure it does it by default.
At least you can enable it.
I'm not 100% sure if they do it by default.
But what they do is, they write twice.
Which means you have this page A that you want to update to page A'.
And therefore before you do this you store on a different place on disk you write as you
Remember that I want to update page as well as remember page a and I want to write a lot of tools
Okay, this you write to disk then you force it to disk which means you you make sure that it's really physically on disk and
Then you perform the update of page a
Okay, and now if you have crash happens value update performance is right
So if you get a partial write here, so 2 in the beginning, 1 at the end, no problem because my second place here still knows,
so this place here still tells me that I have to do this write. So when I come back again, I see, oh, there was a pending write,
and then I redo the write. Okay, so then ultimately this page will be in the correct state.
Now it could be of course that this write here fails, but that's okay, because then we can use this marker trick from IBM
So to realize if my write here was complete and if it's incomplete, I just discard it because I know that my original page was not modified
Okay, so with this thing you can cope with partial writes
But this is quite expensive because we write everything twice. So it's complicated to implement
This is an absolute nightmare. It would be much better if the hard disk itself would guarantee atomicity in writing
Unfortunately, the usual interfaces we have from operating systems does not offer this
to tell the operating system please write this here in an atomic fashion
so at least regular systems like windows and linux don't don't offer this okay um now um
in the following we will assume the following namely the most generic setup namely that my
system runs in steel no false update in place and fine-grained locking this is the most difficult
setup but also the most performant. So this is usually what we assume a database to have.
Which means we have to cope with all these problems that we have mentioned before.
And the standard, in a way, you could say the most popular strategy to deal with this is
actually quite a good one. So this is a so-called ARIES protocol. So this is a recovery protocol
invented by Mohan while he was at IBM. Funny coincidence is I think yesterday,
yeah, yesterday Mohan actually had a retirement party at SIGMOD. SIGMOD is the largest database
conference that is just taking place this week. And oh, when you hear this, of course it has
already happened. But when I recorded it was yesterday. So he had a retirement party, so
it has been at IBM for I believe 36 years or so, a long time. But nevertheless he invented this
And this became the standard for database recovery.
So all big database companies implement this.
And this is indeed a good protocol.
It has some quite good strategies.
And I will discuss them when we come
to the technical details.
But basically what the ARIS protocol does,
it records all changes that you perform
in a database, in a sequential file,
and does it in a clever way so that we can handle
crushing restarting and so on and in this log file we store redo and undo information so read
information that means what do we have to do to do this change again and under information says
i remember what do you have to do to restore the system as it was before now so redo how to
repeat my execution and undo how to remove the state now interestingly um aries does something
that's called physiological logging,
which means that the redo information is physical,
while the undo information is logical.
So I will explain the exact details,
what this means when we come to the redo and undo phases.
But I say, so this is slightly asymmetric.
So redo and undo is not stored in the same way.
So conceptually these are different.
Okay, now, so when we run the database systems,
and I have my database.
So here this is my database box.
I get from application, I get transactions.
And of course they update my database buffer.
So as this all the data is a change
and the database buffer is then synchronized
with my physical medium on disk.
Okay, so this is my regular processing.
And parallel to this, I have my logging here.
So all changes that I perform,
I've written to the log buffer.
So log buffer is then written to a log file.
And for this, with this log file and my database state,
I can do R1, R2 and R3 recovery.
So if my transaction rolls back, I can use my log file to undo my changes.
If my system crashes, I can use the log for the database state plus the log file to
bring the database in the state as it was in the moment of the crash.
Now you see two more outputs here, namely the database archive,
This means backups basically and the log archives.
So this means you write your log files somewhere safe on a different machine, hopefully.
So somewhere where it's, so the log file itself is kept in your own machine for performance
reasons, but for safety reasons, you also want to write it somewhere else in the log
archive and this archive medium we need for R4 recovery.
So if my own machine goes down in a really bad event, so I lose my medium, then we use
the database archive and the log archive to reconstruct the database state even in this
catastrophic event. Of course this is expensive and slow, so therefore we hope that our full recovery
never happens. Okay now what about the log buffer, so the things that we use in memory to
record all changes. So basically what this means here, we have a certain change and then when the
next change comes we add it to my buffer and add it to my buffer and add it to my buffer
so i always write here new records whenever a change occurs and of course at some point my buffer
is full and so here we here we see my my insert so this is my current insert point and the insert
point here moves to the right and of course at some point my buffer is full and then this happens
or a bit earlier hopefully i start writing out these entries here to disk so i write them to disk
And then of course I get new space.
So everything that has been written is free again.
So then I continue inserting.
This is the concept of a ring buffer.
So I insert at one end and I take out at the other end.
When the two ends meet, then the ring buffer is full.
And then I'm forced to write something to a file
to get more free memory.
Now on a slide, this looks like an easy thing.
You just have a ring.
So you have basically here you have a reader.
So this is how far you have read.
So this is a reader walks in this direction.
The writer walks in this direction.
And of course they must not meet
because when they meet it's full.
And now interesting question is how do you implement this?
I mean, I can draw you a nice picture of such a ring,
but how do you implement this?
Now the obvious way to implement this, of course,
is to just use an array.
So you just, this is all your content.
So and then of course you have a writer that moves to the right and then if you read it that follows the writer
So no problem problem is what happens if my buffer is full?
So then could be that I want to write a log record that starts here
Then it doesn't fit because my array is full
So I must write the rest of my log record here at the beginning
You can do this of course you just build use one array and
Write the first part of the log and the rest at the end
is quite complicated to implement because your log record usually consists of multiple entries.
For each entry you must check, oh do I still fit or does part of me fit? And so this is
meets the logic for writing is not as easy as you might think. Because you have to serialize
out something in an array that potentially wraps around. Actually, a particular elegant way to
implement this is it's admittedly a bit it's sneaky you have an array as before
yeah but now you use your virtual memory management to map this array twice so
this is my my physical array let's call this physical array this of course
hits my memory and then we map this into my logical address space here
So log buffer.
And then I map the same, so this is mapped here.
And then I map the very same array again, behind.
And you might be surprised that this is possible, but indeed it is.
Because we have a logical address, we have logical memory, therefore it is possible to
map the same physical address twice in the logical address space.
and then forcing the address.
Oh, then Windows can also do this with,
I think it's called create your file or something.
You can map the same physical memory twice
and you can map it so that it's immediately next to each other.
And this has some very unfortunate consequences.
Namely, when you write something here,
like you think you're writing here
and the second part of course crosses behind
the end of your log bar file here
because this part here is beyond your log buffer.
But what happens is that because these two errors
are in reality the same, physically the same,
your right to this place in reality writes to that place.
Or in a physical sense, these two places are just the same.
And so we have two memory addresses
that represent the same memory location.
Therefore we can brutally write behind
the end of the log buffer.
And so if we then just, after my log record is done, I just have to make sure of course
that my writer must continue here.
So I write over the end afterwards, I put my position to the correct end position.
This is a particular sneaky way to implement a ring buffer and I strongly encourage this.
Much easier, of course setting up this double mapping once is a bit tricky, but once you
did this, much easier to use because you can just blindly write and pretend that this wrap
Only when you advance your pointer,
you must check once,
okay, where do you have to continue writing?
Yeah, so very performant
and not that difficult to implement.
Okay, now once we have our log buffer of all changes,
now an important concept we have to follow
is the so-called write-ahead log principle.
Also sometimes you just use acronym WAL,
so write-ahead log.
And the write-ahead log principle says,
Before a transaction is committed, all corresponding log entries must be written to disk.
And the same before a modified page is written to disk,
all log entries that involve that particular page must be written to disk.
This is called forcing the log.
Which means you must not update a page and you must not acknowledge a commit
before the corresponding log entries have been written to disk.
And you know that written to disk is a pretty strong requirement.
So this does not mean you have to have to issue a write call to a file, but you must
be sure that it is really on disk.
And this means you issue, usually this involves something like for example, write plus fsync.
which means you tell the operating system please write this and afterwards you do an
fsync call fsync tells operating system please make sure that my changes are really on disk
which means that if i lose power so if i have power failure and i come back my changes will
be there for sure this is not the case for a regular write because if you just do a simple
write then the operating system says yes i got your write and usually everything works fine but
if power goes away could be that the write does not does not hit the disk as it's still in flight
and you don't know when it will be done but if you use um write followed by an fsync
excuse me
If you use write followed by an f-sync, then you can be sure that your write has hit disk.
And therefore we can rely upon the fact that we can read it again, once we come back again
with new power.
So this write-adlock principle is required for durability.
Because this means that once we have acknowledged the commit, we are absolutely sure that we
can preserve this data even if my database crashes, if power goes away, whatever.
And because I know that all changes by this transaction have been stored in the log and
they have been stored in a secure way so that if power goes away, I will not lose my content.
Okay, now, even if you do this, you have to be a bit careful, because when you write the
log, you have to realize that disks, the disks that they are using are not byte addressable,
which means you cannot write arbitrary small things.
Instead what we can store are larger chunks.
Unfortunately we don't really know how large the chunks are.
Traditionally, the size was 512 bytes.
Now, nowadays you have sometimes disks
that have larger blocks.
For example, I believe some of them are two kilobytes.
I believe 2KB is a pretty normal block size
on a modern disk.
Yeah, so, but one of these two you usually have.
And so what could happen is that you perform,
first you cannot write something smaller
than this block, two kilobytes or half a kilobytes as well. And what happens is, if you crash,
you might perform a partial write. Because look at this picture here, assume we ignore this problem.
So we just write a log file, this is the end of my log. And by unfortunate circumstances,
this ends at position 300 or so, which is not a multiple of 500 triff and also not a multiple of
to clear it and then you want to write a new log record so you want to write new
entries here and so you issue a write in reality you cannot write this new
content is impossible what you do instead is you look at the beginning here so you
look at this block and rewrite the whole block because this is the smallest thing
you can write and you cannot write this is few bytes instead the operating
system for you will read the previous entry at your new data and write back back again yeah and
this is somewhat dangerous because it could be that your system crashes in the moment that you
perform the last write okay we know this and we usually we cope with this but yeah but this means
you can't destroy your previous content because what some disks do is if they crash during a write
they have filled your disk with zeros so therefore it could be that the whole block here will be
zeroed because we did crash, but note that this block contained data that was already
committed, namely this one here.
So I destroy my lock entry by writing something at the end.
This is of course very, very nasty.
So we must not do this.
Therefore, what you should do instead is when we flush the disk, when we write the lock
record, so my lock record was only to 300, but I pad it.
means I add data that I don't really need just to make the size right.
So I pad it with zeros.
And then I'm sure that the size small log is always a multiple of 512 and then this
problem cannot happen.
And so then I'm sure that I'm always writing full blocks.
Of course you have to figure out well how large the blocks are this, but if you use a
power of 2 that is reasonably large enough, like 4 kilobytes or so, then you are on the safe side.
or actually you can ask your disk.
So you can use operating system interfaces
to figure out how large the block size is of your disk.
And then you can make sure that you are always
a multiple of your block size.
But definitely this is something you have to take in mind.
So because partial writes are dangerous.
Yes, the related problem is partial write of pages.
I've already talked about this.
And there's also written on this page,
some of these issues can be solved by hardware.
And this is of course the best way to solve this,
solve this problem easily.
Just use a small battery and then it can guarantee you
that you will never get a partial write to a block.
So we can tackle this,
but unfortunately most people don't have
this kind of hardware.
Now, so for most people,
the disc is a bit unreliable,
at least if you're in the presence of crashes.
Therefore we have to think about this.
So recovery is unfortunately full of nasty little details
You have to all make right to guarantee
that we survive crashes.
And of course, another bad thing about recovery
is that usually it doesn't occur.
And so really hard crashes,
like you go down in an inconvenient moment
and you have a partial right to it.
This is super unlikely.
Most of the time it never happens, but it can happen.
Yeah, and this also means that you must expect this
and you must also test this code,
even though it's unlikely to happen,
does the right thing in the presence of this unfortunate circumstances.
And now when such a situation occurs we must do a restart.
So we have my system here, you see the x-axis here is time.
So time progresses at some point here transaction 1 begins, sometimes later transaction 2 begins,
even later transaction 1 commits.
So at this point now of course the changes of T1 must never be lost.
at some point T3 here we have a crash
and transaction two was still in flight.
Transaction two did not commit yet.
And therefore we call transactions like T1
a winner transactions.
So they are winner because they have committed
before the crash.
And we say transaction two is a loser transaction,
a loser because they did not commit yet.
And then we come back, they must be removed.
Now so when we come back, we must replay the winners
and we must undo the losers. Also that afterwards the system behaves as if T1 has committed and T2
never occurred. So this is how the system must be after successful restart. And because T2 didn't
quit, therefore it must be vanished from our system. And in the ARIES protocol we achieve this
by using three phases. So first the analysis phase, in the analysis phase I look at my log file,
So this is this here is my log.
This is my log with all my changes.
So I read the log file from front to back and and analyze this analysis.
And during the analysis I figure out what are the winner transactions who have committed
and what are the loser transactions who have not committed.
Okay.
Then I, the second phase is the so-called redo phase.
Again, read my log.
And during that phase, I repeat all operations such that the database was in the same state
as it was in the moment that it crashed.
Note that we also redo loser transactions.
So even though you could say, who cares about the losers, you nevertheless have to do this.
And I will explain to you why when we talk about implementation of undo.
But you redo also the losers, you redo winner and loser.
And this means that you bring your database in exactly the same state as it was when the
system crashed.
Because the losers were there, they were just in flight.
And afterwards we undo, and this video by the way we do backwards, we do a backwards
pass over the log and we undo the losers.
So which means we remove all the changes that were performed by loser transactions.
And now you could think, okay, why redo the losers if you undo them anyway?
The problem is they can affect each other.
Perhaps the most obvious example is think about a B-tree.
When a B-tree page is full, the page is split of course.
So it could be that here, there are some transaction 1 that performs an insert in this page.
Page is full, let's say here there was ABC.
Now transaction 2 wants to insert value D, is full, therefore we split this here,
and now we have AB and now empty space, and now we have CD.
This here was uncommitted.
Now, another transaction comes and inserts a new value B2.
And this can do this here.
And now, or perhaps they make it, make it even more drastic.
Let's not insert B2, but insert value E here.
And now this one is committed,
while the previous one is not.
Now, if he only redo the winner,
so then, and the split, of course,
here was performed by a loser transaction.
So the split of this page here into, let's call this page P1, and this is a new split
and we get a new page P1 and the new page P2.
The split of P1 into P1 and P2 was performed by a loser.
Therefore if I in the redo phase, I would not redo the split, then the database system
would not know that the new value e must occur on the page two.
So therefore to correctly place all the changes by the winner transactions, I must also repeat
the loser transactions because the losers affect the winners.
Of course, afterwards we undo the losers, so afterwards we undo what the transaction
did, but nevertheless we have to do it in this way because otherwise we cannot safely
reapply the changes by the winners.
Okay, and therefore in the final step we undo the losers.
So this is just a picture that I draw. First phase, forward pass over the log.
We figure out who is winner to loser. Then second phase redo, again forward pass over the log.
We apply all changes by winners and losers.
Third phase undo, we go backwards and we undo all changes by losers transactions.
Now, what do we actually write into this log record?
I say in the log we record all the changes that are performed.
Yeah.
So what we do actually write.
So, um, we store a number of elements here.
First one, log sequence number.
This is just conceptually just a monotonic increasing number of, for each of those of
manage mains, first record, second record, third record, and so on.
So the log sequence number, monotonic increasing number.
Now, in most implementations, this number does not really exist.
Conceptually these numbers are in the log.
In reality, what you will often use is, you will use the byte offset in the log file as
log sequence number.
Because clearly the byte offset is monotronically growing.
So as you add new values, say we get larger offsets, therefore we will use the byte offset
in the log file as log sequence number.
And now on the slides and also in most textbooks,
we claim that we really write a number
in the log record, like one, two, three, four.
As I said, usually don't do this in the implementation.
And of course you can, you could,
but there's no strong reason to do this
because we can just figure this,
we can just use my position as implicit number.
Now our second entry here,
we record which transaction this is.
We need this information to figure out,
yes or no.
So therefore we must later figure out
if it was a winner or loser.
So for each change we record which transaction did it,
then which page was affected.
And then how can we redo this change?
We'll talk about this in a moment.
So we record, what do you have to do to redo this change?
Then what do you have to do is undo this change.
So redo and undo information.
And finally, previous log sequence number.
So what was the previous change by that transaction?
And we need this to undo the transactions.
Because remember we start at the end, if you look at the last change of a transaction,
we undo this one, and then we use this previous LSN to figure out what was the previous change
of this transaction.
And then we also undo this one and so on.
So we use this chaining here to undo all changes by a given transaction.
Now, what about the content of this undo and redo entries here?
So in the redo entry, the easiest case to store the redo information is so-called physical
lodging, which means the after image.
For example, you could just say, hey, this is page one and this is a new content of page
one.
So this is the most invasive form of redo logging.
the after image. Now, practice is a bit large. You don't want to write the whole page even if
something is more or less changed. Therefore, what you could, for example, store instead is,
you could say, okay, on this page one, go to byte offset 50 and then write the following 20 bytes.
So this is a kind of data encoding.
And you could code write even more complicated information
like insert it and shift everything to the right as well.
Yeah.
So this brings you then from physical logging
to logic logging.
So logic logging says, okay, what do you have to do
on this page to bring it to the same state
as the after image is?
Yeah, and how exactly you implement this is up to you.
It depends on also what kind of changes you want to do.
Nevertheless, even if you do something about to consider here logical lodging, Ares requires
that this change is physical in the sense that it affects only a single page.
So you can encode the change on this single page in an efficient manner.
So something that is more small than just a copy of the whole page, but nevertheless,
it must affect the page and must allow you to reconstruct the page from its previous
state.
And you will see in a moment why this is so.
Then the undo information, now the easiest implementation again is physical logic.
So the before image we just say, okay, well, how was before?
But this is often not enough.
Yeah, like think back again about your B tree example.
So when record splits, so it could be you have a page here and let's call this page one.
the value A and somebody inserts the value B
is not committed yet.
So when the transaction rolls back,
B must be removed.
But now somebody else splits the page for some reason.
So we again have A and some other stuff here.
And then B has been moved to another page, page two.
But still when the transaction rolls back,
I must undo this, so I must still remove B.
And so somehow I must have now a mechanism
to find the B on the new place and remove it,
even though there's some different,
if it has been moved to a different page.
Now, therefore, ARIES uses physiological logging,
which means the redo is physical.
It means talks about a given page.
So undo is logical.
Undo would say, to undo this, please remove B,
wherever B is.
So then we can re-traverse my B tree
and find my B and then I can remove it.
Yeah, while the redo is physical.
Also, the big difference between the redo
and the other phase is, while I'm in the redo phase,
inconsistence. Remember we don't know what has been written or not. Therefore in the redo phase
I cannot safely rely upon the fact that for example my index pages are valid. Could be that
my index has not been repaired yet. I could have damaged pages. Well after the redo phase is done
my database is again in a consistent state. I still might have uncommitted transactions but all
All data structures are valid.
So all my indexes work and everything.
So after redo, my physical storage structures are repaired and therefore I can safely perform
logical undo.
While during the redo phase I cannot safely perform logical operations that go beyond
a single page.
Within a single page I can do this, but beyond a page I cannot because I don't know if this
other page has been repaired already.
Therefore, in the reader phase, we must be more conservative than we can be in the undo phase.
Okay, and so this again talks about this components here.
Log sequence number, I have already said, monotonic number that uniquely identifies
the log record and a typical choice is we use the offset within the log file,
which means the log sequence number is implicit.
And the transaction is just the transaction ID of the transaction that did perform the change.
Page ID is the number of the page that was updated.
Note that if we have a change that affects multiple pages, like the split of a Btree page,
then we must write multiple log records.
Now, so each log record is only allowed to affect one page.
So one log record per page and the previous lsn this tells me what was the last change
by the same transaction.
We need this for undo and here it says we need this for performance reasons.
Of course in an abstract sense this is redundant because we could just scan my log file backwards
and so we could just move over my log file and then I will find my previous log record
at some point.
But it could be that this previous log record is far away and I want that my rollbacks don't
therefore I use this extra entry here to quickly find my previous log record.
Okay, yeah, and then here, note there's a certain asymmetry, we have physical redo,
which means my redo affects one page and only one page, and I have logical undo,
which means my undo can potentially affect multiple pages.
Okay, now here's an example how a log record could look like.
So I have two transactions, T1 and T2, and what they do here, you see on the left and on the right,
So left of here you see the operations, right of this line you see what is written to the log.
First both transactions begin and the right log record begins transactions. Note that usually we
don't do this. So usually my first log record is implicitly this is the beginning of transactions
because I see this. But now this here is a textbook solution therefore we explicitly write a beginner
of transactions into my log.
So I say here first log record transaction one did begin and had no previous change.
Okay.
Then transaction two does begin had no previous change.
For the reads, we don't perform any logging because reads don't modify my database.
So I don't write anything.
Then comes the write here.
Time point six transaction one writes a and is a new value of a is 50 smaller than previously.
log record, log record 3, says transaction 1 modified page A and the effect was that the value A on that page was reduced by 50.
And if you want to undo this you must increase A by 50.
Okay and the last change position transaction was record 1.
Then transaction 2 performs a write to C and again we write a log record saying page C was updated, we increased C by 100.
If you want to undo this, decrease C by 100.
And the last record of this transaction was two.
Then transaction one does another write to B.
Again, we write a log record here, page B was affected.
We increase B by 50, last record was 30.
Then we write transaction one commits
and the last change was five.
This of course is important because this record here
allows us to figure out that T1 is a winner.
And so when we restart and we see that T1 is, we see this commit message, we know that
T1 is the winner, therefore we must preserve all changes by T1.
If instead we scan the file and we do not find a commit entry, then we know that transaction
is a loser, it is still in flight, then we must undo the changes.
Okay, and last year transaction two continues, writes page A, and then here we see, okay,
somebody decreased a by 100 if you want to undo this increase a by 100 last entry was four
and then transaction two commits so this is how the log looks like
and so in the analysis phase we read the log and so log contains begins to commit and abort entries
and this allows us to figure out who is the winner and who's the loser now so i scan my log
Whenever I see a beginner of transactions,
I know a new transaction starts.
So I know this transaction exists.
Then when we see a commit of that transaction,
we know that it's a winner.
If you do not see a commit,
or if you see an explicit abort,
then we see that the transaction is a loser.
And if you see an easier commit abort,
then it takes an implicitly loser.
And the winners have to be preserved
and the losers are removed from the system afterwards.
Okay, in the redo phase,
database into a consistent state remember that we are running a no force
strategies this means that some changes might have been only on in memory or not
on disk yeah and could be that some changes are incomplete like a bt split
also only one could be that one page has been written the other one has not but
the lock nevertheless contains everything
and um for the uh to bring the database in the same state we
as it was in the moment of the crash,
we do a forward pass over the log.
Remember each log entry affects a single page by design.
And the page contains a log sequence number.
If you remember back when you talk about the buffer manager.
So we have the log sequence number of the change.
So therefore what you do is we load the page from disk.
We check if the log sequence number of the page
is less than the log sequence number of the entry.
If yes, the change in my log has not been applied yet.
Therefore, I do apply the log entry and update the log sequence number.
So I remember what was the last change on disk.
And then I continue processing my log.
This mechanism here, so comparing the log sequence number on disk to my log sequence
number on my page allows me to figure out if a log entry has been applied already or
not.
And this is important because otherwise I might apply this same log entry twice and of
course it's unsafe.
Think about this example here.
We said, if you want to apply the change,
in decrease a by 50,
you are not allowed to do this multiple times.
Because every time you do this, a goes down.
Therefore I must know if my page
already contains this change or not.
And I can figure this out by comparing
the log sequence number.
If the log sequence number is less than three,
then the change is not included.
So I must do it.
If it's three or more, then it is included.
So I must not do this.
So this is a trick to handle the state.
And you know, afterwards, after my reader phase,
my database is a known state,
and it was the state that it was in the moment of the crash.
Everything has been repaired.
All data structures are valid.
So now I can continue processing.
And of course, what I will do next is,
so undo phase, undo all loser transactions.
So during the analysis,
I remember the last sequence of each transaction
Transactions that have already been aborted,
they can be ignored because they have already been removed.
So in fact, they will have no last operation,
but active transactions,
which are not extensibly,
that have a last operation that have not been removed already
must be rolled back now.
And we read this log backwards.
We always follow the last sequence number
to jump from log entry to log entry.
So this was the last one.
point as the previous one, the point as the previous one.
And so on.
So we move it up backwards to the lock.
We undo all the changes.
And then the database is, the transaction is gone.
Note that this undoing of the transaction produces
new lock records because we, of course,
we must redo the undo later.
And so undo means we must remove the transaction
from the system.
And if you should crash later, then of course
we must do this again.
the undo of a log record creates new log records and we will talk about this in a moment when
we talk about compensation log records okay and one very important concept here for restarting
is that the restart must be idempotent idempotent means you must it must be possible to do this
as often as you want and you still get the same database date you know so here you written
of A is the same as undo A.
You can undo as often as you want.
The same as redo, we can do the redo as often as you want.
This is pretty important because otherwise it could be
that your restart destroys your database.
Because what I mean, you could think,
okay, why should I ever crash repeatedly?
But I was told this is actually quite a common occurrence.
Think for example, your hardware is 40,
like your power supply is unreliable or so.
Therefore your system crashes
because your power supply is unreliable.
Then it comes back again,
the database has started again,
it says, oh, I crashed, so let's do restart.
So I again do the three phases, analysis redo undo,
and while happily doing the restart,
the system crashes again,
because power supply was unreliable,
it's still unreliable,
and it takes a moment
until a human recognizes this problem.
So the system crashes and comes back again,
does restart, and crashes,
and comes back again.
we can have repeated restarts.
And so system must cope with this.
First, it must be correct.
And second, another important property
is that differs between areas and older systems.
What ARIES promises,
I didn't explain you yet how it achieves this,
but promises that even if you fail repeatedly,
the number of log records that you will write are bounded.
And so there's not an unbounded,
the log record volume that you write is bounded.
And this is again important for repeated failures
because otherwise you make things worse
by filling up your hard disk
and at some point your hard disk is full
then you have a real problem.
And also the other mechanism will allow us to do this safely.
So, and here you see an example picture
as you will say we have a number of operations
that we perform and we, so one to six
operation with double borders here so operation one and three and five and six are done by
transaction one and the other one are by transaction two okay so this is my model so i execute this
and at some point in time i crash and now what i want is an edempotent restart and we get this
by writing compensation log records okay so basically we remember what we have done so first
First we, of course, when we restart, we redo everything.
Now, so we redo all lock records, all seven.
Then my data is in a consistent state.
Now I must undo transaction two.
So I must remove all changes, but of transaction two, which is this one and this one and this
one.
And I do this backwards, which means first I undo change seven.
And for this I write a new record, namely, this record says, please undo the effect of
seven or if you formulated positively.
So do the change that will undo seven.
And now you set the undo next LSN.
So what was the last change by this transaction?
And this one points now not to seven, but to four.
Remember we can crash in any point in time.
So it could be that after I have undo seven,
I crash again.
So then I restart.
And then in this case,
I would redo everything, including seven prime.
seven I would reduce this two and then I would continue undoing and the next
one to undo is four and again I said the next thing to undo is two and then I
undo two and then I said the next one does nothing because then I'm done okay
and after this so I write three new entries here namely
conversational record seven prime four prime and two prime after this I'm done
never write more than three it doesn't matter if I have a crash repeatedly if
I always write three records and nothing more.
Okay.
And this gives me an EDM potent restart.
Because I can figure, when I restart,
I can figure out if this change was already in my database,
just by comparing the log sequence number with this number.
And if the number on the page is higher or equal,
then I don't do anything otherwise I redo it again.
And I can do this as often as needed.
Now so the same here.
This also gets a new number.
book and the book calls this s prime. In reality, of course, we would have to call this 8.
Remember, we need monotronic numbers. So this would be 8, 9, 10. Conceptually, of course,
it's the inverse of 7, the inverse of 4, the inverse of 2. But in relative, of course,
we give some increasing numbers. So then we can figure out if my number is included on a page or
not, just by doing a simple integer comparison. So then, yeah, this is my log record after restart.
So this was my original log and now I have three more entries, namely undo the seven
and you note that we only formulate this positively because we might have to redo this undo.
So then if we write a compensation log record that says, okay, compensate seven, this means
transaction two modifies page A and we do increase A by a hundred and note that we never
undo a compensation log record.
So a compensation record only contains redo information. No undo information. Okay?
And we say redo increase page by by a by
100 we remember this was my
My previous entry for my page and the next entry to undo is 4
Okay, and then we write the next a composition record
4 prime again transaction 2 modifies page C C is decreased by 100
This previous entry was seven prime and the next entry to undo is two.
Okay.
And then here we say, okay, two prime transaction two, no pages, two pages affected because we
are just done.
It says the last entry was four prime and then we are, we are, we don't have to do anything
more.
So this, when we reach this point here, transaction two has been eliminated from our system.
So then we are done.
redo this if needed.
Okay, so for a compensation log record, it looks more or less like a regular log record
with some small differences here.
The wheeling is the same.
So log sequence number, transaction page and redo, this is the same.
But then we store the undo next LSN to the pointer, to the next operation to undo.
so first we have no undo information so we only redo a conversational record
and then we remember what is the next entry to do yeah so now uh you could ask yourself why
stores is twice in relatively only interested in one point and so we could just say the previous
lsn is undo next lsn no it's another other way around so we could store the next lsn in the
previous lsn strictly speaking is not necessary now the original implementation of arias did this
values for debugging reasons because if you have it like this or with both you
can quickly figure out if your log entries are correct and you can traverse
them quickly and check if everything is right strictly speaking you don't need
both it would be sufficient to store the undo entry in the previous LSN
okay and now this is of course the hard case namely there when we have a
full crash and then continue.
We can all use this for partial rollbacks,
like transaction can do operation one, two, three, four,
and then says, oh no, no, I did a mistake.
So I roll back part of my transaction,
not everything, but just undo four, undo three, undo two,
and then I continue with new operation five.
Okay, and this is supported by this mechanism here,
because we first start writing one, two, three, four,
Then we realize oh no I want to undo something then undo four undo three and then I
Oh sorry I misinterpreted my own arrows I don't undo two I only undo three and four
two keeps alive and therefore afterwards I write record five
continuing with this logically we only do one two five the effect of three and
four is removed from a system and these partial rollbacks are necessary to
implement save points i'm not sure if you're familiar with this in secret and
secret you can define within a transaction save point and then you can
say so you say okay i'm here and after later some later point you can say roll
back to save point and then you forget everything that happened since that
save point but then you can still continue after the save point so you
don't kill the whole transaction but only some part of the transaction but
this doesn't require any special magic because our mechanism already exists
anyway we just use a regular mechanism here with compensation lock records
to handle this.
Okay.
And now, one problem of course that we have in our
redo and restart mechanism is that we have to read a quite large file.
Yeah.
So we first, we read the log file once to figure out who is the winner and the loser.
Then we read the log file again to figure out if a page contains a change, yes or no.
And this of course means that not only reads the page as a log, but also reads the corresponding
page.
And this is of course a bit expensive and I would like to not do this.
And the mechanism to avoid reading that large part of the data is for checkpoints.
Basically what you do is at some point in time you write in your log, okay, currently
for example here we could say this is my point in time and I say at this point in time transaction
Transaction one was active and transaction two was active.
And you will see, we also write something more about
the pages that are modified,
but in particular, we can remember
what was the transaction that they're running.
Now you see already we have this checkpoint here twice
and this dotted line, this end line.
When we say checkpoint in reality,
this is like a checkpoint span
because we need some time to write my checkpoint.
So therefore we say here,
This is the end of my checkpoint and we say it's begin of course t1 and t2 were active at the end
T1 has committed already t2 has committed and t3 is running
But nevertheless, we take a slice of my time and then we record who was currently running
And of course if I have this information this means
Everybody who
Comes before I don't even have to I know for sure that they are committed yet
Everybody who comes after, I know for sure that they are not committed yet.
Only the people who are within my checkpoint, who are active within my checkpoint, then
I have to see if they are still alive.
Now how you create your checkpoint and also how complicated your handling is, depends
on how you build it.
So one is transaction consistent.
Transaction consistent checkpoint means I only do a checkpoint when there is currently
no running transaction.
Now, so this is the most invasive, but also the easiest to implement this checkpoint.
So you say, okay, I have transactions in the beginning, transactions later, but this point
in time, no transaction was running.
If you have this, this means, this is your point in the log.
If you have this, this means analysis only has to start after this log, this checkpoint,
because I know that only later entries are running transactions.
Also, I only have to redo afterwards,
at least if in the moment that I do my checkpoint,
I flush, so I force all my dirty pages to disk.
If I do this, then my redo can continue
with from this point in time,
because I know everything was before my checkpoint
is already flushed to disk.
Okay, and the same with undo,
my undo also never goes beyond this checkpoint.
And also transaction consistent checkpoints
are nice to have, make your research cheap.
The problem of course is how do I get this?
Because I would have to have a moment in time when there is no running transaction.
Sometimes this is not easy to get because there are always some transactions in your system.
Now the next weaker form is an action consistent checkpoint,
which means you do have transactions but you stop them for a moment.
So you mean you don't abort them but you say please stop processing like using a mutex or something.
Then you do your checkpoint, you write all your dirty pages to disk and you write to
disk which transactions are running.
And then when you have an action consistent checkpoint, you have to analysis only from
the latest checkpoint to the end.
You have to redo only from the latest checkpoint to the end.
Of course the undo potentially has to go beyond because you still must undo all changes of
running transactions.
So how far you have to go depends on the min lsn.
So what is the minimum sequence number written by any active transaction.
So the undo goes beyond my checkpoint,
but analysis and redo goes,
only starts there.
Downs it again, of course,
is I must stop processing,
which also might not be easy to implement.
Therefore the most generic one here is that one here,
fuzzy checkpoint.
So what you see here,
so at some point in time I start,
I say, okay, I want to do a checkpoint
and you remember who's currently active.
and then you start writing out all dirty pages to disks.
And at this point in time,
we have we write all dirty pages to disk
and then we are done.
But of course the system can at least potentially
continue running while you're doing this.
So therefore my check restart here
becomes more complicated.
So from my check point,
I have to do analysis only from the check point afterwards
because I know my check point contains the list
of all active transactions.
more transactions later so i have to scan this now my redo can start when where i am plus the
minimum dirty page lsn so what what is the log sequence number the smallest log sequence number
of dirty pages that are still in the system after the end of my checkpoint because there could be
new new dirtiness introduced in my checkpoint so this i must record i must do some more redo
And of course with undo, again, min is n, what is the minimum LSF, n, of any active
transactions.
So this is the most F to do in the undo phase.
Restart becomes more complicated if you use fuzzy checkpoints, but the big advantage of
fuzzy checkpoints is you don't have to stop your system.
You can do a checkpoint while your system is running.
Therefore all commercial database systems in practice use fuzzy checkpoints because these
are the least invasive.
So in a fuzzy checkpoint you don't have to force modified pages to disk.
I mean you can, or at least some of them, but you don't have to.
But what you definitely do is you store the page IDs of dirty pages and then here is a
set of dirty pages is all modified pages and the min dirty page ID is a minimum log sequence
number that has not been written to disk.
Now I said pages are not forced to disk usually what you will want to do is you look at this mean page
Dirty page lsn and if this is a very low number
Then you want to force two pages on disk because it could be that you have a page that is very hot
So that is modified all the time and then the min dirty page lsn is a very small number
Where of course the oldest change to this page
Has not been written to disk can be quite long ago
And if you see that this is long ago, then you write this page to disk
And then of course you get a higher much higher
LSN on that page and this brings your min 30 page LSN high. So therefore when we say
When we are not forced to disk it might be a bit too strong. We say are not necessarily
This is
You don't have to force them to disk, but sometimes you want, if they have very old
changes on them, then you want to force them to disk to make your restart faster.
But you definitely collect all dirty pages and what was the log sequence on this page.
So this brings me to the end of my recovery chapter.
Check my timing.
Oh, I have 10 minutes left.
Yeah, so I can start with already with the next big part, namely, so far we talked about
a lot of problems that we have in like how do we store, how we run a transaction, how
we run concurrency and so on.
But what we did not talk about yet is how do we do efficient query processing.
But of course this is what we are particularly interested in.
most of the time is spent on running complicated queries,
at least in analytical databases.
Therefore we want to do this as quickly as possible.
Okay, and this is the next large part of the lecture.
And I just want to start with this.
I will not go very far.
So motivation is,
so why is this thing called set-oriented processing?
So usually what the system wants to do is
you want to process large parts,
instead of individual data items.
So this is contrary to what you usually will do
if you just write to some small programs
that does some operation.
So the most, I think the most common construct
as it people use to operate a data,
something like a for loop.
I like you take a data item,
you loop over a list, compares this data item
with all the entries on a list.
Now this is extremely common pattern.
And so, which means you have,
we are basically record oriented.
So we take one record,
we look at some other records
some operations I mean good thing about this kind of program is that it's very
easy to understand very simple code betting is this doesn't scale yeah
because this kind of operation like you look at all correct pairs of records or
so tends to lead to n square behavior so we here the example given on the
site is consider two lists now so if you want to figure out what elements occur
on to both lists of course we can implement this easily using just two
on the first list, we loop over all entries on the second list, we compare them, works
three lines of code but is n squared in runtime.
Because we look at all pairs.
And usually n squared is unacceptable.
In database systems n tend to be in the millions or billions.
A million squared is a really unpleasant number, you don't want to do this.
So n squared algorithm we usually cannot do.
The most expensive we usually allow is n log n.
So therefore we want to have operations that do this quicker.
And of course we can do this quicker.
Like if we, instead of looking at individual elements, we look at the whole lists, then
we can do this, for example, in N log N, because what we can do is we can sort both lists and
then we do a list intersection in linear time.
So the expensive part here is sorting, intersections then is cheap.
Sorting we can do in N log N and therefore we can handle even very large lists efficiently.
do this because we see the whole list as input and therefore the name set oriented processing,
we take the whole set and do something with the set. Okay, so set oriented processing has
many advantages over looking at individual records, like we can pre-process before we can
processing, we can sort, we can hash, we can build index structures also. For individual elements,
this would never pay off building a complicated data structure, but for a large set of elements
then it pays off to do this.
So we amortize the cost over the set.
This brings me to a more efficient algorithm.
Also this allows me to cope with memory limitations.
Like if I realize, oh, my set is too large,
I cannot fit it into memory,
then I can handle this.
Also if you have a large set,
we can parallelize this easily.
So this is all good.
So in the end, set-oriented processing is much better,
much more scalable.
Downside, of course, it's more complicated.
the think about the list intersection example a trivial list intersection is three lines of code
and this dog's low an efficient list intersection is fast but this is not three lines but you know
depending on what kind of tooling you have probably at least say six or seven lines if you have to do
everything yourself including sorting then probably more than 50 or 100 lines of code
also depending on what kind of tooling you have okay so accelerated is more complex but more scalable
okay and now when we are inside and in a relational database system all operations
that we want to perform are expressed using relational algebra and so therefore by so
So everything I do here is modeled as an operator, for example a join or scan.
And so we have here we have three kinds of operators.
So this is called a scan.
So we just read an input, read an input, also scan and scan.
Here we have a filter, also called select.
So we filter my input and here we have a join.
We take two inputs and we combine them.
And each operator consumes zero or more input relation and produces one output relation.
So this is a model.
and these operators are inherently set oriented. Now if I am a pendantic,
strictly speaking they are not set oriented, they are back oriented. So back means multi-set,
because my relation of course can contain duplicates, at least in the general case.
If I have a primary key, my input is duplicate free, but if I have no primary key, then I can
have duplicates and therefore of course operators must cope with duplicates. But this is basically
my model and the question is now of course how to kind of implement this efficiently okay and
so now just looking at my time now only five minutes left so i think i will stop here now
before the next lecture i would recommend you please again look at the algebraic operators
because we can now come back to this and i assume that you all know how this work and we will now
look at what they do and how we can implement them efficiently.
Okay, but this I will want to continue in the next lecture.
Okay, thank you.